welcome to this video so what is them
what what else can i play what else is
there ok let's do it once ok Knight f6
pre-move that's funny he pre move so um
I went for the orangutan which is
probably the most offbeat opening that
is still about playable yeah white is
probably not not ver SI m and then after
one before maybe but if he is vs justice
it's not much um yeah i mean not as like
in in g4 wear white is really worse but
before it's just the queenside this sum
is a bit more yeah you can you have a
little bit more leeway on the queenside
so um how do i go here maybe just 93
yeah he's having that we've got got an
enormous tension down porn tension but
doesn't look too bad i really don't get
it how can you play this move in one
second okay okay it's not my game it
just it just the most committal move
ever yeah and it just ended spade in one
second okay let's see
so maybe here we are trader of those
bishops yeah this is why it is a tricky
moves widest given this d 4 square which
is not exactly bad okay he has a night
only five or nice and good but I know I
tend to think about those things and not
just play the move which is probably why
he'll lose on time of
yeah bishop at the dark squared bishop
are traded now maybe you should take and
think about Bishop g4 that would be a
move okay so let's go f5 and look at it
as our fix that a six pawn still Bishop
g4 could be nice no he rather wants to
give me 85 him yeah I wonder can I take
that in the first place no way
especially fight the end ripping my
queen what is sick idea okay
okay let's prevent that anything going
to g4 I mean prevent that
k I don't know if f4 is a move
let's put the bishop on f1 first to
cover h3 maybe maybe a queen move was
better yeah that doesn't move that I was
thinking about but I don't I couldn't
really believe it is it is the right way
to go as he completely ignores the five
but maybe it's still okay
ideas queen h h 5 next to try to pick up
that pawn ok let's try is yeah I wonder
here maybe maybe look here would be sick
so he cannot take on a five now sg5 a
son that tech okay that's a bit bit
awkward he is really threatening that so
I have to move through may be here Queen
f25 there is no tactic right no
we'll have 225 always looking at that
night they're on g5
ok well let's go back then I know that
nothing's going to hit on age three okay
what is the idea pawn to g6 maybe Wow
after the Queen trade this is just lost
for black just lost not more not less I
think let's see chicks on a six I just
you just want to win on time that's idea
maybe
yeah i've got 1 minute 20 so does it
look like I should lose on time easily
so over tell how do I win actually I can
take take those pawns maybe that says
it's the easiest actually just take
those pawns or the source quickest time
morning then yeah maybe let's get rid of
that first no Jake take all the pawns
check three pounds oops no shouldn't
take that one he can't cover it for a
moment
really check check check check yeah the
only thing is still made up that you
still have to check check
black resigns yeah I'm sorry probably
ever get some flak again for that game
but I don't understand those kind of
instant moves that are totally totally
commit alia like a five Andy form I mean
this is the most committal sequence of
moves ever and it's played in two
seconds yeah I don't know I think white
is quite in quite good CPM 95 cheeks
txtx takes him it's interesting though I
t4 is a good square but of course he has
his ideas as well but he never really
played them I thought we should be four
here they are trying to trade the light
squared Bishop send their forget
possible access to those squares that
would have been interesting he didn't go
for that plate this okay five again
Bishop g4 but it felt like he doesn't
want to play it anyway that's neat yeah
I cannot take now quite funny Queen
Queen strap if no square so h3 h4 will
be one for Bishop f1 just to be be safe
let's say yeah computer is some on on
about equal but now after Queen edge
five it gives white a substantial plus
would be 34 loopy six actually and now
looky be one here now this is already
winning for y to the position oh yeah
the sequence of moves by black was
probably just just not great I get day
six porn he has really no good way to
prevent it here and he could have taken
e6 but this is a good move he simply has
nothing nothing that he can play and
down 95 rupee 6 yeah this shocked me
because it's just a losing end game I
mean it's not even trying to to somehow
muddy the waters are trying to swindle
or something it just is just flat-out
lost him
now now I just traded everything down
into them the rook endgame it's probably
not even the the quickest way but it's
the simplest way the rook endgame is
just a complete win because it's not
just the a pawn those pawns are all week
don't think that that way here was was
was good enough just pretty pretty
simple yeah that was one before um yeah
I think in this this kind of setup for
black of course you can play that but
it's not the the most ambitious against
this opening um I think really am even
players who don't play efore or so they
should go he 5v5 is the best move here
and after that white has to be careful
to equalize it's it's possible maybe but
it's not not much fun like we should be
tools we should be to ship here you
should be fine 96 this kind of thing is
very very decent for black but probably
why it can equalize if he if you play as
well okay well thanks for watching